Yes, Python has a ternary operator.
Theternary operator in many languages since 1960
has looked something likethis, using the question mark.
But Python is way too cool for that.
So in Python, it's written using "if"
And to top it all off, it's not even referred to
as a ternary operator, even though it totally is!
Instead, an expression like this in Python
"a if some condition else b" is technically
referred to as a conditional expression.
But anyone will know what you mean if you
say ternary operator or if expression.
Side note: Why is it called ternary
and not trinary?
I don't know, maybe if
you're an English expert,
you cancomment down
below, and I'll pin the answer.
The way it works is it
first evaluatesthe condition,
and then if it's true, gives you the
first thing; otherwise, thesecond thing.
This is kind of out of
order of the way that it's written.
But it's more in linewith how
you might say it out loud in English.
The value is "x" if "x" is bigger
than 0, otherwise, negative "x."
A lot of different alternatives were
considered,but they literally held a vote.
And this "if" syntax won
out over using a question mark.
Butimportantly, the condition
is the first thing that's evaluated.
And the expression that's
not returned doesn't get evaluated at all
which is important in a case like this
where we don't want to divide by 0.
It's a similar idea as
short-circuiting for "and" and "or."
It's basically just syntactic sugar for a
full"if" statement, but it also returns a value.
And keep in mind that
this is Python.
And inPython, it usually doesn't check
whether a value is literally "equals equals true."
Instead,Python uses its
notion of truthiness
where something like a non-empty
list would be considered true,
but an empty list would
be considered false.
In general, it's good for short definitions, like
setting the default value of a mutable argument.
But do your best not
to go overboard.
It quickly becomes unreadable if you try
to stuff too much stuff into one expression.
Just like with any other operators,
bewareof operator precedence.
Where you put or don't put
parentheses can change the answer.
Theternary operator has the lowest
precedence of any operator in the language.
So the parentheses,if you were
to put them in, look like this:
Now for the surprising part, the Stack
Overflow answers for this question.
Luckily, the first answer
is the one that Iwould recommend.
But number two with
over 900 upvotes.
And number three with over 400 upvotes
tell you to do something completely bonkers.
These answers are
from 2008 and 2009.
Backwhen these answers were written,
they served a completely legitimate purpose.
But todaythey should not
appear anywhere in your code.
I wish Stack Overflow
had a way to flagan answer
as severely out of date without
hurting the reputation of the original poster.
After all, if you tried to ask this
question again today to get a modern answer,
itwould surely be
closed as a duplicate.